c'est l'objectif numéro un de leur
saison après avoir trôné en tête de leur
poule de nationale 2 de basket ball les
joueuses de l'entente le
chesnay-versailles joue les playoffs
maintenant tout est remis à zéro et on
est bien placé pour commencer avec trois
victoires et une défaite mais maintenant
on doit oublier toute la première partie
et se concentrer prendre les matches les
uns après les autres avant de rêver à la
montée en nationale une il fallait
d'abord s'imposer face à furdenheim le
pivot virginie aurensan soulage le
gymnase mont boron et débloque le
compteur sur la première possession
les yvelinoises mène rapidement 17,7 et
ne se laisseront jamais reprendre porté
par une salle surchauffée à blanc
le premier match des play-offs c'est le
match pour nous important peut-être
parce que c'est vrai que c'est ça qui va
déterminer si elle gagne ce soir elles
sont toutes leurs chances si elles
perdent allait être dur après comme tout
au long de la saison régulière les
coéquipières de chantal descoings
s'appuie sur une défense solide vous
plaît à une adresse au shoot est
excellente il n'en fallait pas plus pour
que la messe soit dite à la fin du
troisième quart temps 62 45 les
dernières minutes sont une formalité
score final 72 56 avec cette victoire
les joueuses de vinko berdych son
deuxième à la différence de points
derrière sainte savine qu'elles
rencontreront lors de la prochaine
journée le 27 avril pour ce qui
s'annonce comme le choc de cette poule
de play off